hallo hallo leute hier ist wieder eure
mal war der tete de und heute teste ich
game of thrones trinks denn es gibt ein
offizielles kochbuch es ist nicht so
cool wie schmeckt das offizielle okay
ich will so viele leute die nicht
abgeschaltet haben hey hey geht's euch
gut ja wie ist das leben so passt alles
cool
wir testen heute game of thrones drinks
denn jeder der so ein wahnsinnig
verrückter game of thrones fan ist wie
ich weiß dass morgen am 15 04 heute in
amerika aber morgen bei uns letzte und
achte staffel startet ich glaube so wie
ganz verkraftet muss ich ehrlich sagen
das ist mein leben okay ich bin ehrlich
mit euch das ist mein leben das
verhältnis ist so kelly zu harry potter
und vanessa hat so germer france nur als
vergleich
man soll so noch der letzten folge der
großen schlacht so alle so und die
anderen so und die anderen so wir sind
wild walker wir bringen nicht alle oben
ganz ehrlich ich überlege die ganze zeit
während auf dem thron sitzen wird und
meine theorie ist es dass der thron
einfach so aus versehen von einem
drachen geschmolzen wird und ein gips
intro nicht mehr weil ist es nicht so
dass dieser thron mit diesen
geschmolzenen schwertern ja eh von dem
drachen gebaut wurde also kann ihr
theoretischen drache auch so wollte ich
nicht sorry ihr möchtet jetzt aber nimmt
rings sehen und natürlich wissen wo kann
man game of thrones überhaupt kommen
natürlich online mit dem sky ticket für
den start der achten staffel gibt es
dort natürlich wieder ein angebot ihr
könnt einen monat für 499 also für den
halben preis game of thrones schauen
auch alle anderen serien aber ich sag
euch da gibt es jetzt nicht nur die
achte staffel
sondern auch die erste und siebte ich
habe vor zwei wochen die siebte nochmal
komplett durchgeschaut und wieder auf
den neuesten stand zu sein
natürlich mit dem sky entertainment
ticket wo auch sonst und sky ticket hat
da immer schon ab 3 uhr nachts die neue
folge auf deutsch also ich gucken
natürlich auf englisch aber ab drei uhr
nachts gibt es auch auf deutsch aber ihr
müsst schnell sein denn das angebot gibt
es nun bis zum 17 04
um 23 uhr 59 schreibt euch das auf und
dann könnt ihr euch ganz einfach
registrieren und los geht's
was ich ganz super mega toll finde ist
dass man es monatlich kündigen kann
ich hasse es wenn man so lange vertrags
zeiten hat oder bindungen und da kann
man es einfach monatlich kündigen und
wenn jetzt nicht wie ich ein doppel tür
kühlschrank habt auf dem ihr auch stream
könnt dann könnt ihr das auch mit eurem
laptop machen mit eurem smartphone
smardtv tablet vielleicht schafft sogar
euer röhrenfernseher hinaus er schafft
es nicht
ich wäre aber gerade man kann es auch
mit einer spielekonsole gucken natürlich
findet ihr den link zum angebot unten in
der video beschreibung und jetzt geht es
weiter mit dem video der erste ring den
wir probieren ist ein eisgekühlter
grüner minister sollen die getränke
kommen nicht in den folgen vor sondern
in den büchern und das ist aus the dance
track sklaven mädchen rutschten durch
licht und schatten und trugen krügel mit
bier und wein und einem eisgekühlten
grünen trank der nach minze roch in
dieser frühen morgenstunde war nur jeder
zwanzigste tisch besetzt
aha mama so aber kein stark und das
rezeptbuch ist nach ländern sortiert und
das ist aus jenseits der nervosität aber
mein leben okay ich bin ehrlich mit euch
das ist mein leben
und so wird der ministrant zubereitet
erfüllt einen halben liter wasser in
einen wasserkocher und während das
wasser kocht füllt ihr in eine teekanne
einen halben teelöffel matsche ein
bisschen mehr oder weniger schadet auch
nicht und nun warten wir darauf dass das
wasser fertig kocht man kommen beim
worten zum beispiel tanzen und jetzt
gibt dir das macho pulver mit dem heißen
wasser auf einmal kräftig umrühren
lovelock klopf klopf glaubt mit einer
waage und einem schnapsglas könnt ihr
jetzt 40 gramm honig abwiegen von einem
ins sträußchen nehmt ihr euch jetzt so
viele blätter dass ihr eine ganze hand
damit füllen könnt die teemischung
lassen wir zwei minuten ziehen und jetzt
gibt dir das flüssige gold dar ein okay
das schnapsglas war jetzt vielleicht
nicht die beste idee aber dann könnt ihr
einfach den rest mit einem löffel
auskratzen und jetzt mal eine runde um
gehören eine runde um höhere für den
honig gewinne gewinne gewinne wer hat
noch nicht wer will nochmal ins
ästhetisch fügen wir die fed minzblätter
dazu und noch mal eine runde rühren eine
runde rühren für die windräder gewinne
gewinne gewinne noch eine runde noch
eine runde ein neues glück neuerung
gedrückt hatte um ihn in ein glas zu
fühlen findet ihr ihn am besten in ein
sieb so dass man die fans blätter gut
raus bekommt und zum garnieren brauchen
wir noch zitronengras schneidet ihr euch
einmal so zurecht wie es brauch und
packt es einfach ins glas fertig
ich muss sagen erst nicht so grün wie im
buch dargestellt aber man kann es immer
mal wieder auf früheren und dann wird es
wieder ein grüner riecht sehr nach minze
und jetzt testen ich mag eigentlich den
geschmack von matschie nicht und
deswegen habe ich eigentlich erwartet
dass ich jetzt ein bisschen denke aber
das geht voll klar
seit echten minister der süß schmecken
wie sie nach zitrone liegt wegen dem
zitronengras ja okay jetzt immer
probieren meine nichte ist da denn nach
zu trinken von alkohol
ach so stand es nicht alle mit alkohol
nicht dass ihr das versteht
ja aber auch irgendwie ein bisschen
anderes ich muss sagen
drei von fünf thron throne 355 franz
voves ob das zweite getränk für euch
nicht mega hammer super dollar honig
süßer wein aus dem buch ist storm of
swords oder das ist die kapitel nächste
ist das buch oder jenny nahm ihr morgen
mal unter einem per simone baumann der
in dem terrassengarten wuchs mit sunway
servierte ihr enteneier und hunde wurf
und einen halben becher gesüßten wein
gemischt mit dem saft einer limone der
honig lockte die fliegen an
doch der duft der kerze verjagten sie
wieder wie der satz schon sagt es ist
ein wein mit honig und zitrone und sowie
dazu bereitet für unseren honig süßen
wein brauchen wir drei 150 milliliter
weißwein diese menge können wir uns ganz
einfach mit einem messbecher abfüllen
dazu kommen noch zwei esslöffel honig
und jetzt hören wir so lange bis der
honig sich komplett im weißwein
aufgelöst halbiert die zitrone und
presst den saft aus wir brauchen
ungefähr ein viertel zitronensaft also
ein viertel von einer zitrone fügt den
zitronensaft hinzu und jetzt wird noch
eine runde gerührt eine runde für den
zitronensaft und den honig und dan weiss
war ein länger länger meine damen und
herren lecker lecker diese flüssigkeit
könnte jetzt ein tolles rustikales
weinglas einfüllen und ihr fühlt euch
direkt wie der neris in games und das
ist ja ich bin wirklich gespannt auf den
geschmack weil ich niemals darauf
gekommen wäre
honig oder zitrone in weißwein
reinzufinden zu weißwein passt irgendwie
nur mineralwasser ohne weißweinschorle
zu machen habe ich auch noch nicht was
andere sind gemischt prost moment
oha also dem kochbuch steht dass der
super für einen warmen morgen geeignet
ist es ist jetzt 14
ich fühl mich schon komisch ich weiß
wenn in der hand habe aber er schmeckt
wirklich mega gut also bis in die mit
weil natürlich honig honig wein aber mit
der zitrone und so auch nie voll
erfrischend und von interessant also den
honig schmeckt man auf jeden fall raus
ja es halt ein bisschen sauer als
normalerweise
wenn ich mir vorstelle wenn man so seine
freunde einlädt für eine neue folge game
of thrones und sowas dann anbietet finde
ich irgendwie mega cool so aber alle
weinkenner gerade so 'oh mein gott sagt
sie macht honig und zitronen ein
weißwein das gehört doch nicht rein bin
ich schon bereit
5 von 5 thrones der hat mich wirklich
überzeugt
der nächste drink ist ein wahrer
hochgenuss für die ich sag mal gut
betuchten menschen dieser welt und zwar
geeiste milch mit honig und safran um
drauf und ich habe das erste mal safran
gekauft und dieses fläschchen kostet 4
euro 99 und safran macht man einfach nur
so auf sachen drauf schauen auf der
verpackung stand auch rotes gold und ja
das würde ich genauso bezeichnet die
geister milch mit honig kommt vor in
game of thrones und das rezept kommt aus
klings landing die hauptstadt hättet ihr
gerne eine erfrischung ein paar datteln
vielleicht ich habe auch einige äußerst
schmackhafte personen wein bekommt meine
verdauung nicht mehr wie ich fürchte
aber ich kann euch ein glas geeiste
milch mit honig anbieten bei dieser
hitze ist sie äußerst erfrischend
woolsey und somit wie gemacht für dieses
rezept brauchen wir mal einen topf in
einem messbecher füllt ihr 250
milliliter milch abgibt die jetzt in den
topf und dann lasst ihr die milch bei
mittlerer hitze
langsam aufwärmen bis der dampf
aufsteigt wenn der dampf aufsteigt dann
könnt ihr zwei esslöffel honig
hinzufügen die milch so lange verrühren
bis sich der hohe nicht komplett
aufgelöst hatte dein glas das mit eis
gefüllt wurde könnt ihr nun die milch
hineingeht und nun kommt mein absolut
lieblings küchen flex rotes gold meine
damen und herren safran ist sowas von
teuer aber sieht auch ein bisschen so
aus als ob man ein alchemist wir haben
von dem zeug dann nehmen uns jetzt mal
was uns einfach so obenauf die mitte und
an die man so ein bisschen zum tippen
das auch noch mal um drauf länger ich
würde mal sagen da geiste milch mit
honig prüft leute die iss zu geist und
jetzt nochmal geeister mir nicht mit
honig krust leute ich weiß ja nicht was
es ist aber dass safran gibt so eine
gelbe irgendwas von sich ab also es
könnte ja safran öl oder so sein ich
finde aber auf jeden fall dass der sehr
was hermacht der sieht komplizierter aus
als er eigentlich ist
dafür dass safran ist und so sein gelben
zauber abgesetzt hat schmeckt es so
unglaublich gut hier schmeckt es einfach
nach leckerer milch mit honig in kalt
und hier hat das irgendwie eigentlich
nichts schmeckt so lecker
ja denn niemals milch mit honig kite
getrunken air france muss man gut
verteilen sieht schöner aus
hier muss ich auch wieder sagen wenn man
seinen gästen so was anbietet und sagt
hey wir gucken jetzt gerne frauen und
guck mal das ist aus game of thrones
hammer test
ich brauche ich brauche mal eine zweite
meinung aber sagtest du nicht so viel
safran im mund kriegs irgendwie schmeckt
es bitter wenn man drauf links problem
war dabei weder probier doch mal da es
schmeckt gut und schmeckt komisch ja das
finde ich auch es sieht auf jeden fall
aus holz öl drauf wer ich bin es mir
egal ich bin heute grosszügig fünf von
fünf frauen kommen wir zu drink nummer
vier und trinkt nummer vier hat mich ein
bisschen erschrocken denn ich habe erst
beim zubereiten gesehen dass man
ungefähr ein bis vier monate zeit für
dieses getränk braucht ich habe dadurch
ein klein tourist gemacht uns ein
bisschen verändert es ist birnenbrand
wein von den tierischen und wieder aus
jenseits der ne rossi ich habe süßen
roten auslöst und volantes und vom labor
weißen aus list birnenbrand wein von den
feuerwehren pfeffer rein das zeug
besteht aus brandy und birnen und so und
das muss man halt zusammenrühren und
einen monat lang stehen lassen da hat
mir sein das sind so lang gedauert
deswegen habe ich die zubereitung ich
würde sagen für cocktails die
banalisierung und so wird zubereitet
willkommen zu dieser special folge drei
komplex die ballern aber nur mit mir und
nur einem cocktail zuerst brauchen wir
vier reife birnen die wir gut ab waschen
und abtrocknen anschließend schneiden
wie die köpfe ab und versucht mit einem
löffel ganz ganz vorsichtig das innere
der birne auszuschneiden oder zu kratzen
oder zu schnitzen es ist nur sehr sehr
wichtig dass ihr diesen inneren strunk
nicht komplett raus zieht denn sonst ist
unten ein loch und dann kann man da
nichts mehr rein füllen das innere von
der birne kann man aufbewahren und ein
bisschen zucker und brandy draufmachen
und
experimentieren jetzt geben wir zucker
in unserer aus geschichten werden und
versuchen das alles gut zu verteilen
jetzt kommt da überall ein richtig guter
schuss brandy rainha mit einer hübschen
platte serviert wie das sogar richtig
gut aus und das ist ja hmm hirnen
branntwein yummy yummy schmeckt's groß
zickezacke zickezacke habe ich nicht so
die andere getränke ohne alkohol sind
alle so süß und so und das ist so hier
birne und schnaps brandy post halleluja
das macht die brust war ja ist okay also
ich finde brandy schmeckt halt eben
nicht so gut auf jeden fall gepumpt und
es ist wieder so ein ding was man halt
so seinen gästen anbieten kann
eigentlich kann man alles hin gästen
anbieten ich brauche es jetzt nicht
jedes mal sagen aber dann eher so als
bauwerk die scheiße mann ich möchte auf
jeden fall würde das ist also ich muss
nicht drei monate lagern versteht aber
umso länger smart umso milder wird es
kann sein bei wenig worauf ich noch
richtig gespannt bin ich dieses birnen
much muss also ganz toll ich wollte halt
nicht das innere von der bühne
wegschmeißen deswegen habe ich damit
noch herum experimentiert also man kann
sie auch essen als in der reform indes
nicht wegschmeißen
ich wollte es einfach ausprobieren okay
es ist dass man da was zu kauen hat also
wenn du dein säugling schon zum
alkoholiker machen ich kann mir das gut
vorstellen so über törtchen oder so wenn
man darauf steht das dass er nach
alkohol schmeckt ich stehe da nicht so
drauf waren experiment ist halt ne zu
youtube
trotzdem bekommen die birnen zwei von
fünf es ist nicht schlecht schlecht ist
weg nicht schlecht es ist einfach nur
nicht lecker und jetzt kommen wir leider
auch schon zu unserem letzten drink
zitronen süß er kommt zu schonen
zitronen süd kommt auch dornen und aus
dem buch liest vor kraus ariane zog das
kind beiseite
ihr müsst hungrig sein
wir haben da drin und käse und oliven
dazu zitronen süß zu trinken soviel
solltet ihr allerdings auch nicht
trinken bei 250 gramm puderzucker kann
ich mir gar nicht vorstellen warum und
so redest zubereitet wir brauchen zwei
orangen und ultra viele zitronen also
sechs und weil es so kompliziert es aus
zitrusfrüchten den saft heraus zu
pressen zeige ich euch das einmal ganz
kurz
ihr nehmt euch eine zitrone und
schneidet sie in der hälfte auf dann
nehmt ihr euch eine hälfte und drückt
sie richtig kräftig mit der citrus
presse aus dann nehmt ihr eure citrus
presse und kippt den saft in einen
anderen behälter und das wiederholt ihr
mit jeder zitrone und ich meine wirklich
jeder zu tun und natürlich auch mit den
orangen und dann habt ihr auch schon das
beste vitamin c lebenselexier aller
zeiten und weil uns das natürlich viel
zu gesund ist nehmen wir jetzt noch 250
gramm puderzucker also schön rein da und
jetzt kommt der deckel zu und dann wird
ordentlich geschüttelt ist ihr merkt
dass es überall raus spritzt diese
zuckersüße citrus flüssigkeit wird jetzt
mit 600 milliliter wasser gemischt weil
sie so wie ich keine riesen karaffe habt
könnt ihr euch das auch erstmal
mathematisch zusammenrechnen und dann
die jeweiligen prozentsätze in ein
kleineres gefäß für mathe macht so viel
spaß jetzt seht ihr wie ich versuche mit
einem t filter die flüssigkeit von
seinen citrus überresten zu befreien was
nicht so gut funktioniert hat also habe
ich ein sieb genommen und ein paar
stückchen haben sich noch dort durch
geschlichen
das ist aber nicht so schlimm auch nicht
dass die hälfte dran vorbei gekippt ist
und so einfach geht dieser drink und das
ist zitronen süß bei der zubereitung
hatte ich das gefühl dass es nicht die
richtige farbe bekommt es ist nicht so
gelb wie auf dem foto aber es hat eine
schöne farbe jetzt bin ich wirklich
gespannt wie das schmeckt da ist halt
möglich viel puderzucker drin aber kommt
leute letzte drink groß die ihr klein
häuschen border brandy sitzt mir wagen
und weiß ist dass ich weiß nicht warum
man puderzucker am geschmack erkennt
aber es schmeckt nach puderzucker und
extrem süß und extrem sauer also ich hab
es wirklich ein rezept gemacht ich habe
aber das gefühl dass man das noch mit
viel mehr wasser mischen kann
ich glaube doch nie aufhören zu trinken
also ob ich mir das so machen würde weil
sie auch nicht im kopf die man endlich
so ultra süße soraya du magst süße
sachen die ist es immer nicht zu sauer
probieren schmeckst du den puderzucker
man schmeckt so habe ich weiß gar nicht
wie man es beschreiben soll
puderzucker es schmeckt als ob man so
einen keks essen würde mit seinen nazi
zuckerguss das ist so dieser puderzucker
geschmacklich mac wiegen butterplätzchen
mit zuckerguss das bekommt von mir zwei
frauen von 5 wenn ihr euch schon sechs
zitronen zwei orangen kauft dann macht
er lieber was schönes drauf wie zum
beispiel wurde ich so sehr weil ja
selbst das ist mein absoluter gewinner
heute ich liebe den geschmack es kann
auch sein dass meine geschmacksnerven
einfach komisch sind aber dieses getränk
gehört für mich auf den thron
jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall gut drauf
ich mein zucker noch mehr zucker ein
bisschen alkohol und safran läuft
genauso wie das sky angebot
ihr könnt nämlich mit dem sky
entertainment ticket für 499 game of
thrones schauen also registriert euch
noch heute und in der video beschreibung
findet ihr den link und ja schreibt mir
einfach wie supi
ihr findet das game of thrones wieder
losgeht und ich hoffe damit euch hat das
video gefallen wenn es so ist dann zeigt
es mir mit einem daumen nach oben
abonniert gerne meinen kanal falls ihr
das noch nicht getan habt und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder schreibt
mir gerne was ihr sehen wollt neues wie
schmeckt es wird mir nicht noch einen 3
kopfball an dass ich mir aus so fiel das
letzte war einfach über einen tag auf
platz einzelnen trends also wenn es
dieses video wieder auf platz 1 für die
trends schafft dann werde ich auf jeden
fall auf einem guten weg ist